is that is clearly an inflatable craft  it is an inflatable craft that I think  if I'm looking at it correctly here that  that is folded up on itself that looks  to me like an awful lot of people  bouncing on the edge and and stuck  wedged almost in the middle of that but  I mean have you seen anything like this  never I've never seen anything like that  at all it would seem that perhaps the  boat didn't capsize but actually  um got a puncher in it because these  things are filled with air so it looks  from that picture as though some of the  um air cylinders have um  of of punctured and the boat started to  folding on itself it must be incredibly  frightening for the people on board  because they don't all seem to be  wearing life jackets either